hey there i'm philip molina this is a
breakdown of the flash season 2 episode
6 enter zoom and holy crap was this a
good episode let's get right into it so
we opened on intense fight scene between
the flash and dr. light who is here to
kill flash because zoom really doesn't
feel like doing it himself for some
reason dr. light appears to succeed but
not really and we jump back 72 hours
earlier now of course we'll get back to
that we then find out that Barry was
trying to work with dr. light to bring
zoom to him so you can just get all of
this over with and if you remember this
is the same idea that our two flash Jay
Garrick was like yeah I'm not helping
you fight zoom right now you're gonna
die I don't want to help that but of
course they say people have to learn the
hard way and he so is going to and then
we see dabbawalas flash back but it's
actually over to earth to there we meet
his lovely earth-2 daughter Jesse did
you catch the reference he makes almost
immediately
that's my Jess how he's so quick yeah
it's a pretty Ogden hos revelation that
this is the flash shows version of Jesse
quick another speedster that plays a
bigger role in the DC Universe anyway
this is definitely all before Jesse's
got all that speed stuff going on
however I do gotta say a lady speedster
could tell a whole new story and make
things really interesting you know cuz
then you've started imagining all kinds
of stuff that could happen with her and
Barry and I could wink right now but I
think it's pretty obvious without the
wink then at the station Patty and Joe
discuss some details about finding dr.
light and listen to what Patti points
out about light did you know that light
energy can be turned into hard light no
and on the other end of the spectrum is
invisibility now the invisibility bit
obviously for shadows the scene to come
but the hard light bit I think that
might also be foreshadowing something
huge light that can actually have the
impact of a physical object not only do
I think that's a direct reference to the
powers of Green Lantern but anyone
notice where we hear Lynda is headed to
say hello so friends out in Co City Co
City home to Green Lantern now of course
that's just earth one Linda and I'm not
sure if she took Cisco's light gloves
with her but something's gonna come from
that I think now let's go ahead and
start getting to the action of the
episode Cisco falls for a trick that you
actually think Cisco might have been the
only person who wouldn't have fallen for
it
has kind of been done in a lot of other
movies and shows it's where he thinks
dr. light has escaped because her cell
is empty and there's a pile of clothes
but of course he's wrong and then we get
that same the camera is the invisible
person style of attack that we saw back
in Holloman and then that way she goes
one thing that I actually liked about
the pile of clothes of means that dr.
lights powers are more realistic than
you'd think because she can only apply
them to her actual body so often
metahumans can do like all kinds of
crazy stuff but also it kind of
magically works on their clothes too so
this not only sets up the use of her
clothes later for the fake doctor light
plan but it also makes it feel a little
bit more real that she would have to get
naked for no one to see her anyway
then Cisco tries to grope doppel Wells
because his new powers let him see
flashes of memories and other moments in
time and he's hoping it's gonna explain
to him what Doppel Wells is real deal is
I love that they've turned vibe into a
verb here because then it allows for
this hilariously awkward exchange what
did you find about me saying what did
you fight about nothing Khan why what's
there to vibe on I don't care how many
times they say it vibe as a verb will
always be a little sexual I want you to
buy them yeah we then get another
multiverse flash back over to earth-2
again and we see some of the fun
differences over here on earth too by
the way you can see this cellphones are
just like ours except they've got
terrible stabby things right where your
ear goes they also watch their TVs in
freakin portrait mode and like right
there officially I think now or two is a
terrible place our movie theaters also
portrait they're like in like
skyscrapers what is this I hate it oh
also did you notice they get their news
from channel 52 so channel 52 news is a
kind of news outlet that covered DC
stories in the comics and the 52 is a
reference to lots of DC stuff
most recently the new 52 but also there
are fifty two versions of earth and DC
basically 52 is just an important number
to look out for and in fact did you see
it a few minutes ago when Cisco is
walking down that hallway boom
clearly someone at DC is a huge fan of
the b-52's
I'm sure more than a few of you noticed
that on earth to the news report
revealed that Oliver Queen's dad Robert
was the one that survived the Queen's
Gambit disaster Oliver was the one that
died and so Robert was the one that
became the hooded vigilante and the
arrow so what's really interesting about
that is that we know in this DC TV world
they haven't really had any Batman stuff
and any time they wanted to use a Batman
type story they just switch it out to
being Oliver and an arrow story kind of
like how the League of Assassins wants
to destroy Oliver's hometown on arrow
but they also wanted to do that to
Gotham and Batman Begins but anyway in
the comics one of my favorite storylines
is a flash one called flashpoint and
that takes place in an alternate reality
where Batman is not Bruce Wayne but
instead it's his father Thomas Wayne who
has taken on the mantle the back you're
his father you're Thomas Wayne so if we
know that in this TV show world they use
arrow to tell Batman stories and
Oliver's dad has become the arrow and
this parallel dimension is kind of like
the alternate reality of flashpoint then
I think all signs are pointing to us
getting this flashpoint story at some
point and it's a huge story like it
changes everything about the DC Universe
I don't know when they'll do it but I'm
really excited to see how it'll affect
all the DC shows we then get really fun
training montage that Cisco sets up to
basically teach Linda how to shoot only
Barry in the face I don't want to guess
why Cisco has dozens of cardboard
cutouts of all his friends or what he's
done with them before this instance
right now but this was a really fun
scene nonetheless which also makes what
happens later and how dark it gets so
much more surprising okay my one beef
with this scene is that it's really
obvious that all of Barry's family and
friends are all here hanging out with
the flash and they're clearly all
working with him regularly and even
though Barry isn't doing the face
blurring thing or even much of the voice
altering we're supposed to believe that
Linda has no idea that Barry is under
the mask I mean this guy was her
ex-boyfriend yeah then I guess it's
really obvious why they did not work out
because Linda has no memory of who
Barry's friends are or even what he
looks like apparently now a few months
later Barry takes lead on planning the
rest of the mission not that any of his
friends seemed too confident in his idea
but it is kind of cool seeing him take
the lead since the show's always left
most of the leadership to the brilliant
scientist of the week okay
I know we see Barry and Joe going to the
STAR Labs elevator and holy crap that's
a lot of floors STAR Labs has to be
freaking massive it's like 28 floors
guys do you realize it you have this
much space to work with
like let's spread out just beyond this
one room maybe each of you could have
like three of your own floors easily
when flash visits Linda a moment later
and her confidence is at its lowest it
is worth noting that the character
that's having trouble accepting her role
as a master of light too seen here
sitting in almost complete darkness
not bad flash team I like it also Barry
reveals his identity to Linda and while
I get why he does does anyone have a
count on how many people know his secret
identity now like he can't still get mad
when Felicity or somebody accidentally
calls him Barry when he's in his flash
attire cuz it wouldn't be crazy for them
to assume that he has already told
everyone in Central City ok finally the
whole episode has built up to this
moment the moment that we saw the
opening and it's this fake scene it's a
trap that team Flash's built to catch
zoom it's always hilarious when normal
decent actors have to play people who
are terrible actors I'm here to kill you
flash so get ready to fry and I love
that detail that the cheesy dialogue was
written by Cisco anyway the plan doesn't
work out a little later zoom does show
up any kidnaps Linda and holy crap
everything from this moment on is
terrifying the episode completely
changes tone and it suddenly feels like
a horror movie
zooms voice is definitely a big part of
that you like to fish with B
and you probably wouldn't be surprised
to learn that we've heard it before in a
horror movie it's the freakin Candyman
and it's also the creepy guy from the
final destination movies scariest voice
ever also look at zooms body there was a
theory at one point that zoom could be
earth twos Barry Allen but yeah that is
not likely unless earth twos Barry Allen
is on like every steroid known to man
flash shows up to save Lynda and when
she gets tossed off the building I can't
help but be totally reminded of when
Gwen Stacy is plummeting to her death
and spider-man tries to save her but
then his actions still end up resulting
in her dead so I'm always super
sensitive to these scenes where a
superhero that doesn't fly has to save
someone that is potentially falling to
their death and it's nice to see Barry
wielding some of his new tricks to save
her by the way the flash character has
always had like so many interesting ways
that he can use his speed but up against
zoom none of these powers are of like
any use at all check out this insane
moment when flash uses his recently
acquired ability to shoot lightning and
not only does it not hit zoom zoom
[ __ ] catches the lightning like in
his hand and he throws it back at flash
you know I have to dissect this moment
the flash in all of DC Comics is
actually one of the most powerful heroes
out there because yeah sure there are
some that are bigger and have other
kinds of cool powers but the speed that
flash is capable of can only be
described as godlike and the reason I
say that is because flash actually is
somewhat based on the Greek god Hermes
who serves as the messenger for all of
the Olympian gods
compared Hermes helmet to the Golden Age
flash helmet and you'll see the
inspiration is pretty direct
but a few moments into this fight where
Barry gets his ass completely handed to
him zoom wants everyone to know their
hero the flash is no
God how can he say that if we know that
flash is totally based on the powers of
a Greek god
well that's because when it comes to the
gods of Olympus sure Hermes technically
count as one but again he's the
messenger of the gods do you remember
who the ruler of the Greek gods is yeah
that's Zeus you might have seen him
before when it comes to Greek gods he is
at the top of the food chain and do you
remember what power Zeus is most
associated with the ability to literally
in his very hands hold and throw
lightning so this moment with zoom
holding the lightning bolt in his hand
that's proof right there that this isn't
flash versus reverse flash level of
fighting this is the mailman of the gods
trying to fight the John Cena of the
gods
basically it's not a fair fight this is
also made really clear in the way zooms
speed is portrayed like considering the
time flash caught a bullet or two maybe
out of the air that was given an entire
slow-motion sequence but here when zoom
catches countless bullets in his hands
it's so easy for him they don't even
dwell on it
and for those of you wondering why zoom
doesn't reveal Flash's identity to
everybody it's a lot more meaningful for
the public to see their favorite hero
utterly defeated remember these people
were recently like let's have the flash
day let's name our coffee flash we love
flash and now it's like seeing your dad
get beat up in front of you which is
like the saddest image ever but if you'd
been unmasked it would have been more
like they just saw a poor kid who never
really stood a chance in the first place
so poor Barry is dragged around like a
pit bull
playing with a rag doll and I think this
becomes that moment in every superhero
show where the hero comes really close
to death and you actually realize he's
not invincible the stakes of all these
battles become much higher than we
previously thought it's happened to
arrow it's happened to daredevil and
it's just incredibly heartbreaking every
time the episode ends with Barry in the
hospital in the worst shape we have ever
seen him and there's a huge revelation
when we find out after this beating he
can't feel his legs and if you're
wondering what moment caused this I
would not be surprised if it was this
part of the fight where I swear to god
it sounds like you can hear Barry spine
being ripped out
it's actually very reminiscent of when
Bane broke the bat god these poor guys
at least they've got old doctor welders
wheelchair in a storage closet or
something okay so that was a story in
those last few minutes probably made it
one of the best flash episodes we've
ever had okay let's get to the title
enter zoom at first read the title seems
pretty straightforward right but it's
actually more clever than you think
this episode is about creating an
extremely elaborate plan with decoys and
a training montage and even I literally
scripted out fake scene and this is
where the title comes in often in the
pages of a script kind of like what
Cisco maybe wrote for this barry and
linda scene you indicate the entrance of
a character with the word enter like
Vader enters or when they're building it
up even more
something like someone's saying okay I
get it you're going out with a famous
person but they can't be that famous you
could write Enter Pope Francis it's a
way to imply that a character of great
importance is entering the scene and is
about to change everything so the title
both applies to the fact that zoom
enters this cute little scene that
they've scripted out as part of their
trap and then the other meaning is
actually a little meta because it's also
the case in this script for the overall
flash episode like the writers wrote in
all this planning in the silly montage
and then in the script for the episode
at this moment when zoom is gonna come
in and absolutely change everything you
better believe they wrote Enter zoom
also smaller thing to note about the
title this was the most badass villain
we've ever seen on the show
he destroyed Barry worse than anything
we've ever seen terrified me and I know
that he's a fictional character and yet
this was just enter zoom like we're just
getting started with him holy [ __ ]
this guy's gonna be insane but here my
lingering thoughts and some other
observations I had the previews made it
look like dr. light is the biggest dummy
she just like runs into a metal pole oh
and also if you're wondering where earth
to dr. light Lynda is they don't tell us
so as far as we know she is still
walking around Central City butt-naked
it's also fun to remember that Linda
Park isn't the original doctor light
Linda's TV show and I don't just mean
the fact that they recast the part from
the reporter that showed up in the pilot
I mean that Cisco and Caitlin actually
referenced an old employee named dr.
light that made a gun that Cisco uses
against destro
back when we first met these people on
arrow to put them belong to Arthur bite
Wells fired him two years ago watch
because he was a psycho so this is dr.
light too also it was pretty unclear if
the speed dampener had any effect on
zoom but if it didn't I think that's a
hint that like in the comics zoom isn't
actually a speedster his powers work in
a completely different kind of mind
[ __ ] way but we'll see if they do
that right after lying about his
blindness before I wonder how Barry's
gonna explain to Patti why he's
paralyzed from the waist down you can't
say he got his legs dilated also anybody
else wondering how they're gonna change
Barry's voiceover next episode
considering his current condition my
name is Barry Allen and I've got the
fastest wheelchair around by the way we
can joke about this because the arrow
already showed us and that flash forward
that Barry's gonna be fine all right
some questions for you guys one do we
think earth one's Oliver Queen is gonna
meet earth twos Robert Queen and are we
could have like a father-son double
arrow team-up which by the way is
definitely a pitch for an arrow TV movie
I want credit on that I'm getting
distracted the question is do you think
it's gonna happen and Oliver Queen
Robert Queen team-up also question two
I'm really loving the cross-dimensional
earth-2 flashbacks and it reminds me of
how major portions of arrow episodes are
told through flashbacks as well so how
would you guys feel if those became a
regular part of the flash episodes for a
while what do you think finally question
3 do you think our Barry is going to
travel to earth - and if so is he gonna
meet Doppel Barry I would love that
because then maybe you'd have to work
with him kind of like how Olivia did on
Fringe but do you think that's gonna
happen all right so that's it for this
in-depth analysis of flash season 2
episode 6 enter zoom and between you and
me we're trying really hard to get these
videos out to you quickly without having
to sacrifice too much of the analysis so
bear with me if I'm a little late
sometimes thank you
and it would really help us out a lot if
you spread the word that we're doing
these because I really like doing them
and I would love for other fans of the
shows to join us on this super nerdy
conversation so share this video with
your friends if you like to also check
out my Walking Dead analysis video if
you watch that show it has some really
good examinations of gory blood imagery
but check that out I'm Phil Molina hit
me up on Twitter at fimo and follow at
new rockstars to find out when her
videos are posting and what else
of going on I will see you in an agent
of shield video or an arrow video or a
Walking Dead video or all of the videos
on the Internet this has been fun bye